[Music]
this morning we're looking at how some
police departments are moving forward
with reforms on their own despite the
breakdown of congressional efforts to
overhaul policing in the 16 months since
the murder of george floyd more than
1300 u.s
people have been killed by police
officers chris vancleave rode along with
a special police car stocked with less
lethal tools to help officers avoid
deadly confrontation
i'm sending a team with a pepper ball
gun police respond to a suicidal man in
june he's got a knife outside the train
station in aurora illinois the officers
called for backup from a social worker
less lethal and after about an hour what
could have been deadly ended peacefully
we're not afraid to try new things keith
cross is aurora's chief of police the
27-year veteran runs the second largest
city police department in illinois the
uniform can be a barrier to someone
who's in crisis and they don't see the
social worker as a threat it's been very
very helpful cross became chief 14
months after george floyd was killed by
minneapolis police officer derek chovin
floyd's death and the protests that
ignited across the country led to
demands for fundamental changes in
policing is policing broken there's no
question that police needs to change in
some very dramatic ways all the arrests
are made georgetown law professor
christie lopez developed de-escalation
training now used by at least 175 police
departments in the u.s and canada a lot
of state and local jurisdictions have
realized they need to step up and they
need to be the ones to lead change is
all it was is arguing we've got to train
officers to be guardians not warriors to
de-escalate rather than escalate force
to prevent other officers from
committing misconduct or causing harm
got the knife
for chief cross that better training is
the key they're going to play like they
practice and so they're going to take
things slow if they can they're going to
try and de-escalate we're going to use
the least amount of force that we have
to use just go ahead drop that knife for
me okay the department just started
using this immersive virtual reality
system got one down it can simulate the
toughest things cops face we're going to
get you the help you need like how to
deal with their own implicit bias when
to use force and when to back away we
can teach the officer to not jump to the
lethal level we got some time if we got
some space on our side let's use that
and if we can end this thing at a
non-lethal level
that's a win-win for everybody involved
we tried the system sir i'd like to see
your hands
my hands are right here and it becomes
very real very fast sir stay in the car
sir stay in the car my response during
this simulated traffic stop was to draw
my gun when the driver unexpectedly got
out of the car
the trainer said that was too early and
could have provoked what happened
moments later when the driver pulled out
a gun whoa sir put the gun down
put the gun down
it becomes real it becomes real and it's
good to watch officers go through that
to see how they react to that come on
just do it for me drop the knife you
really do get a sense for how quickly
you have to decide what you're going to
do
we spent a friday night shift riding
with officer wesley boyer he's driving
one of the department's 16 ll squad cars
the initials stand for less lethal the
units carry things officers can use
instead of their sidearms a gun that
shoots pepper balls and another firing
hard foam projectiles
what's the benefit to having less lethal
cars the more options the more decisions
you can make you could prevent an
officer from having to use deadly floors
a recent survey showed 90 percent of
americans supported more training for
police and departments nationwide are
making changes in june the nypd the
nation's largest police department
announced all 35 thousand officers will
get new de-escalation training
berkeley california decided to shift
enforcement of minor traffic violations
like expired registration to unarmed
transportation department workers
and in san francisco changing training
and policies led to almost 70 percent
fewer instances of use of force by
officers you don't have to go hands on
you can use your voice and your presence
tracy mccrary is a lieutenant in san
francisco police union officer she says
there are always cops who see change as
handcuffs but she sees george floyd's
death as a game changer and that's
changed the face of policing and either
you're going to get on board with that
or this isn't the profession for you
nationally departments have seen
retirements jump by 45 percent and
resignations spike by 18 percent while
the officers staying on the beat are
being asked to keep the peace
while keeping pace with change for cbs
mornings i'm chris van cleave in aurora
illinois
it looks like they're on to something in
aurora but you have to have buy-in from
the police officers too and you don't
always it's interesting when the chief
there says you know get with it or get
out and then you see that nationally a
lot of people are retiring and or
resigning yeah it's good to see those
less lethal vehicles
but i do have family members that work
as police officers they tell me about
these confrontations and they get
intense like that yeah but as long as
they have de-escalation de-escalation
tactics i think they'll have less deaths
you know they have seconds to respond
seconds make a decision very tough it is
a very difficult job